do you need to monitor and protect large
amounts of sensitive data but aren't
always sure where that data is or how
it's being processed and managed today
we'll talk about automatic dlp a service
from google cloud that is built to
minimize the risk of sensitive data
being mishandled or exposed and help you
prevent privacy security and compliance
issues before we continue if you need a
refresher on what data loss prevention
is check out the link in the description
for our getting started with data loss
prevention playlist
first let's understand how dlp
inspection works the cloud dlp engine
inspects structured and unstructured
data and classifies it using what we
call info types our predefined data tags
out of the box dlp provides over 150
different info types including
personally identifiable information
financial data types global and region
specific types and more and you can
extend these with custom info types and
detection rules to meet your business's
needs
for example the dlp engine can tell you
where it found an instance of a credit
card number even giving you details down
to the byte offset where it was found
for bigquery an inspection job can be
configured to scan an individual table
in a data set this will leverage the dlp
engine to perform a deep scan of that
table to look for sensitive data
elements
info type classification can be used to
make informed decisions about how you
protect share and use your data the dlp
engine and inspection jobs are great at
deep scanning data to get very detailed
information
but when it comes to gaining visibility
across your entire organization across
thousands of projects filled with data
sets and tables
this skill can become unmanageable
pretty quickly and writing up some
custom code to scan every table can lead
to a lot of overhead to manage
so
we made dlp automatic and developed a
fully managed data profiling service
that takes away that overhead and pain
it gives you the same detection quality
as dlp and lets you protect data by
identifying where sensitive and high
risk data resides
automatically it generates a set of
metrics and insights or a data profile
from scanning the data among these
metrics are the protected info types
found in bigquery tables free text score
and data risk level
so you gain crucial insights into what
kind of at-risk data you are currently
storing allowing you to take the
appropriate steps to protect it
automatic dlp profiler scans are set up
with a simple configuration and will
scan all bigquery data sets and tables
in an entire organization folder or
project
you may be thinking
these wide scanning capabilities sound
great but what if i want to keep that
detailed view of my data
well you're in luck because this
automatic service was built to fit
perfectly with the previous dlp
functionality those inspection jobs we
talked about earlier
so you can get a view a mile wide and
when needed a mile deep when using these
together
and the fact that automatic dlp is fully
managed allows google cloud to take on
the overhead and allows you to focus on
the outcomes and your business
but wait there's more
continuous monitoring automatically
profiles any new tables you create
across your org and periodically
reprofiles the tables you modify
data profiles are generated in the same
geographical region that your data lives
in making sure to maintain your data
residency
and deep technical knowledge of coding
or embedding isn't necessary to use the
service you focus on configuring it to
your needs turning it on with one click
and consuming the results and you get
all of this with low overhead which
means you don't need to manage or
orchestrate your own jobs so scanning
across your org is a breeze
as a quick example let's say you have
150 000 tables across multiple projects
that you need to scan for sensitive data
like
social security numbers and email
addresses when you turn on automatic dlp
you'll see detailed metrics about each
table and column in your organization so
that you can assess your overall data
risk and gain insights on where you have
that sensitive data
executives who worry about maintaining
security and data compliance can see at
a high level where risks may lie and
data admins who are responsible for that
data can ensure all data is properly
permissioned or considered
de-identifying the data to protect it
and improve compliance
all that with just a few configuration
steps and the click of a button to turn
it on
easy peasy
so let's recap
automatic dlp will
help find sensitive data including in
unexpected places keep up with data
growth that makes it difficult to
manually inspect data and provide rich
insights about data and data risk
allowing you to manage data risk make
more informed decisions focus on the
outcome and ultimately help to safely
accelerate your business while we take
care of the rest thanks for watching
you